um
that's why come over here
hey
she's
come
yeah
[Music]
you know
that's uncomfortable that's
uncomfortable for me
yes
is
i'm happy
[Music]
um
yet
okay
okay
i'm
that happened right after i told you
and you're fine
hey
so easy
hello
yes
oh
okay
yes
here
ah
thank
oh
what's up
is
yes
yes
well i was supposed to have legendary
pretty much any minute
thank you
all right two minute warning on the
press briefing
two minute warning of the press
briefings
so
so
where's that
hi everyone happy friday
we have another very exciting guest
today
uh our set new secretary of the interior
deb holland
who made history when she became the
first native american to serve as a
cabinet secretary
she is the member she is a member of the
pueblo of laguna and
and a 35th generation new mexican
secretary holland has worn many hats
throughout her career she ran a small
business
served as a tribal administrator and
became the first woman elected to the
laguna development
corporation board of directors
overseeing the business operations of
the second largest tribal gaming
enterprise
in new mexico she also became the first
native american woman to be elected to
lead a state party
in 2018 she became one of the first
native american women to serve in
congress
in congress she focused on environmental
justice climate change
missing and murdered indigenous women
and family friendly
policy she joins us today on the second
day of the climate summit
to underscore our commitment to
protecting public lands and
strengthening
tribal sovereignty she's happy to take
just a couple of questions because she
has a heart out and i will
as always be the bad cop and please
welcome thank you again for joining me
thank you so much jim
good morning everyone thank you
thank you so much and thank you jen for
inviting me to be here today
i want to start start off by wishing
everyone a happy
national park week i hope you found a
chance to get out and experience your
public lands this week
the white house is actually a national
park so technically we're all
celebrating a bit
right now i had always wanted to be a
national park ranger and while i didn't
quite land that job yet i'm pretty
excited
that tomorrow night i get the chance to
swear in some junior rangers
all of your kids are welcome to join
during the us army field band's virtual
concert tomorrow night
i think you can find the link on our
website
i i was happy also to celebrate this
morning with the second
gentleman we announced 16 new listings
to the underground railroad network to
freedom program
our park system is our nation's
storyteller and i'm eager to ensure
that these national treasures help tell
a more inclusive and accurate story of
our nation
this week has brought significant news
on climate action
and on issues impacting tribal
communities
and so i'm honored and grateful to have
the opportunity to speak with you
and take your questions today we have no
shortage of work ahead
president biden has set ambitious goals
that will ensure
america and the world can meet the
urgent demands
of the climate crisis while empowering
our nation's workers and businesses to
lead
a clean energy revolution i believe that
a clean energy future is within our
grasp in the united states
but it will take all of us and the best
available science to make it happen
the interior department is in a unique
position to be
a leader in putting our nation on a path
to
achieve net zero emissions create good
paying jobs
and benefit underserved communities
we have taken steps in just the past few
weeks to advance offshore wind proposals
restore balance to management of our
public lands and waters and create jobs
and revitalize land in coal communities
i'll also touch on interior's work to
honor our nation-to-nation relationship
with indian tribes
and uphold our trust and treaty
responsibilities
i believe just as president biden does
that we must engage tribal nations with
an
all-of-government approach and one need
look
no further than the first lady's visit
to the navajo nation
to speak and hear from tribal leaders
and
indigenous people for too long indian
issues were relegated
to the tribal offices within federal
agencies
if we're going to make sure that native
american and alaska native communities
thrive
that tribal sovereignty is respected and
strengthened
and if we are truly to repair our
nation-to-nation relationships
then that means every federal agency
needs to be thinking boldly about our
obligations to indigenous peoples
the significance of being the first
native american to serve in the cabinet
is not lost on me as i stand here today
at this podium i am moved by how
monumental this week alone
has been for indigenous representation
on monday i delivered remarks on behalf
of the us government
at the un permanent forum on indigenous
issues where i affirmed
our commitment to advancing indigenous
people's
rights at home and abroad i talked about
how we're putting the full weight
of our federal government behind a
cross-departmental
missing and murdered unit to address the
crisis
in indian country yesterday i announced
that interior is moving forward to
implement the not invisible act
establishing a joint commission led by
interior and the department of justice
on reducing violent crime
against indigenous peoples and later
today
domestic policy advisor ambassador susan
rice and i will convene the first white
house council
on native american affairs meeting of
the biden harris administration
we're wasting no time we have an
ambitious
agenda and so i'm ready to roll up my
sleeves
and get to work across the cabinet in
identifying and supporting tribal
equities
in the administration's core policy
pillars
last i come from a family that farms
ranches and hunts i've grown up in rural
and
agricultural communities and i know what
it's like to live in a community
that's been left behind these
experiences
underscore well i believe why i believe
so deeply in the work that we do at the
interior department
and why i know that we can and will make
a difference
in the everyday lives of families across
this country
and with that i'm happy to try and
answer your question nancy go ahead
thank you secretary holland can you give
us an update on
the moratorium on fracking on federal
land's new contracts
thank you so much so uh the pause on new
leases
um is still in effect until we finish
a review that is due to the president
that means that the existing leases
are still in effect we are still issuing
permits
on those lands and uh when when
when we finish the review it's an
important review we're talking to many
people we've had it for a gas and oil
forum
uh we've talked to many folks across the
country
when that review is done um then uh
the us and the president will uh decide
next steps
and can you give us a little more
details on how on how that review
works what exactly you're doing and when
you think it'll be concluded
so i can't say exactly when it will be
concluded but as i mentioned we've had a
gas and oil forum
already that was visual the department
folks are talking to governors to
legislators to folks on the ground uh
we're talking to
to it's mostly like getting everyone's
input we want to make sure that
that every voice has a seat at the table
and it's really
that as well as using the science
um and that's how we'll do the review
and
and it'll go to the president but we've
heard from republicans in utah talk
about
their preference for legislation to
expand the size of bears
instead of executive action do you think
there's room for bipartisan work there
or are we probably looking at executive
action from this administration
well i i met with those legislators when
i was in utah the governor the
lieutenant governor
my former colleagues from the house um
um i i
legislators legislate and i think they
should move ahead with legislation if
that's what they want to do
we will get the report done for the
president and
send it to the white house and it will
really be the president's decision
the antiquities act is a presidential
um you know it's it's it's all him uh
he can decide um what i did when i went
to utah was make sure that
again every voice was at the table we
talked to ranchers and farmers we talked
to children
uh who use uh those lands and
um outdoor you know economy
folks and so we're we want to make sure
that we include every voice and
and that's the report that will go to
the president and he'll decide
that's not a different topic really fast
yeah we've heard
so many tribes this year talk about
really struggling with mental health
issues for teens i mean a lot of
communities around the country but just
teens struggling with with depression
during this pandemic
is that one an issue that you guys are
addressing in this domestic council
i can't this is our first meeting so
uh what we're really going to do
initially
is assign committees to each cabinet
secretary
and it will be up to them to look at the
topics
of course we care deeply about this
issue
it's it's one that i know a lot of
people are suffering
from so i appreciate you mentioning that
and
um once we're able to um get a
you know a clear path on where we're
going with the council uh we'll
certainly
let everyone know mario you gotta be the
last one but
we'll invite her back thanks jen thank
you madam secretary um
just piggybacking a couple of questions
just piggybacking off of your comments
at the top about national parks
any reason why they're still at reduced
capacity
when we know that social distancing
outside is uh
is the best possible uh you know case
for covet
well let's first of all i'll say um
we are taking every possible precaution
to make sure that we are keeping people
safe i
i don't ever want to jump the gun on
this we know there's a lot of
vaccinations that are happening
yes our country is safer since president
biden has been in office we're just not
quite there yet
they'll continually monitor that
situation
we want everyone to keep their masks on
the social distance and
and i appreciate the question we can
look into it and
absolutely get back with you and more
business related um
what's your plan for restarting the sale
of oil and gas leases in the us gulf of
mexico
once we are uh once we
so existing leases are already happening
uh
as i mentioned earlier there's not a
moratorium on
even on new leases they're just a pause
so um when we
when we have the review done um
what i'll say is right now permits are
still being issued so
and there's still ongoing leases that
are happening
thank you secretary thank you for
joining us and you're welcome back
anytime
thank you thank you thank you nice to
see you well
happy national park a good thing to
celebrate
okay a couple of other items for all of
you at the top
um as you know president biden just
concluded a historic climate summit with
50 world leaders to show
that america is back at the table on the
first day he
upped the ante announcing that the
united states will target reducing
emissions by 50 to 52 percent
by 2030 compared to 2005 levels
he underscored america's commitment to
leading a clean energy revolution
and creating good paying union jobs
we also want to lead the way here in the
federal government
toward achieving and act in a way that
demonstrates our leadership
on these issues so some examples of our
commitments which some of you may have
seen but
uh include the gsa is committing to
power its approximately 186 million
square foot federally owned
real estate portfolio with 100 renewable
electricity by
sources by 2025. the department of
transportation is taking a comprehensive
approach to addressing the climate
crisis and expanding ways for
all modes of transportation to
transition to zero emissions
examples include funding for lower
emission buses and expanding access to
electric vehicle charging stations
the department of defense is announcing
a plan to complete
climate exposure assessments on all
major u.s installations within 12 months
and all major installations outside the
continental
united states within 24 months using the
defense climate assessment tool
and the epa will fund one million
dollars in grants and cooperative
agreements through
through to work with underserved and
vulnerable communities including
indigenous communities to prepare them
for climate related
impacts so it's an across government
approach
also we wanted to highlight that today
the department of education announced
plans to distribute
800 million dollars in funding from the
american rescue plan for states to
support
students experiencing homelessness the
department also took a series of steps
this week to help
states and districts access the 122
billion dollars in
american rescue plan elementary and
secondary school emergency relief funds
to support the safe reopening of k-12
schools
and address equity gaps exacerbated by
the pandemic also this week
usda issued a broad range of the us
department of agriculture i should say
issued a broad range of flexibilities
that will allow schools and child care
institutions to serve
healthy meals for free to all kids in
the upcoming
2021 through 2022 through school year
roughly 30 million kids participate in
school meals programs
and we know that for lots of kids school
meals are the healthiest meals they
consume
all day due to supply chain issues
during the pandemic usda is giving
schools added resources to maintain the
nutrition standards
of the school meal programs including a
strong emphasis on providing
fruits and vegetables milk and whole
grains
and because as many of you know the
pandemic caused steep spikes in hunger
and food insecurity
relating to as we've talked about a bit
in here one in seven families
struggling to put food on the table
we've also we are hardened by the sharp
decline
from the implementation of a lot of
these funds as you can see in this chart
in the number of american households
that say they are behind on rent or did
not have enough to eat
in the past week obviously there's a lot
of work to go and a lot more
to be done but we can see a clear
positive downward trend
on this chart which is quite encouraging
finally a quick preview of the week
ahead
on tuesday the president will deliver
remarks on the covet 19 pandemic
as you all know wednesday the president
will address a joint session
of congress among other topics as we
talked about a bit yesterday he will lay
out the american family's plan
the specific details and discuss a
number of other issues that are
important and major priorities to him
including
expanding access to health care and
addressing
putting in place policing reforms on
thursday on the president's 100th day in
office
he and the first lady will travel to
georgia to highlight how he's delivered
on his promises to the american people
while he is there he will participate in
a car rally
and on friday he will have additional
out of town travel that we will
hopefully have more details for you
in the coming days uh finally i know
many of you saw this and reported it and
tweeted it but uh we announced this
morning that the president will travel
to the united kingdom and belgium in
june for his first overseas trip
as president this trip will highlight
his commitment to restoring our
alliances
to revitalizing the transatlantic
relationship and working in close
cooperation with our allies
and multilateral partners to address
global challenges
and better secure america's interests he
will attend the g summit
in cornwall which is happening from june
11th through the 13th
he will then travel to brussels belgium
where he will participate in the nato
summit
on june 14th and while in brussels the
president will also
participate in the u.s eu summit with
that
kick us off all right thank you uh with
the
climate summit uh promise reductions and
carbon missions
uh that the president announced this
week without the investments
um in the infrastructure proposal um
can those be achieved and
with that is is that then is there some
red line
with republicans that you have as a
result of making those uh
goals happen well first yes absolutely
it can be achieved
because we have several paths toward
achieving that objective and that
goal some include legislation the
american jobs plan
but there are additional legislative
options there's executive options that
are
are also on the table and of course
working with the private sector and
states and localities to taking
continuing to take
additional steps forward but i'll also
say that we have every intention
of getting the american jobs plan passed
and signed into law as we saw and we
talked about a bit yesterday
there was a republican counter proposal
yesterday
the stage we're in now as we will have
discussions we'll get a full briefing we
expect those to happen
through the course of the next several
days we'll review that plan we'll ask
questions at a staff level and then the
president will invite a number of those
members down here to the white house and
if i can ask just one more
um is the president speaking today
uh with president uh and
with that the turkish foreign minister
said earlier this week
that if uh president biden goes forward
with uh
his campaign pledge on armenian genocide
recognition that it would
harm u.s turkey ties how much idea
weighing
on the president's mind as he makes this
decision whether or not to follow
through on the campaign pledge
especially
with the need for turkish cooperation on
things like afghanistan and iran
i certainly understand your line of
questioning i know there's a great deal
of interest
uh in this particular area uh i don't
have any
uh calls of with foreign leaders to
predict for you
as would be the case with any call we
will certainly provide a readout
once whenever we do a call with a
foreign leader and the president of the
united states and
actually down down the rung below them
as well uh in terms of
delivering on his campaign pledge um i
don't have anything to
preview for you on that front either i
expect we'll have more in the coming
days but
jen on the republican counter offer
now that you've had a chance to peruse
it does the white house have any public
reaction to what they're
doing only a day there's an initial
reaction
as we said yesterday uh nancy we are
uh the president's only red line is in
action
we want to have an exchange of ideas on
both sides uh
and from both sides of the aisle in our
view this is an example of that
uh we're reviewing the details of the
proposal we're starting to have
conversations at the staff level
today we expect those to proceed through
the course of next week we'll ask
questions we'll exchange additional
ideas uh but uh our view this is a good
start and we look forward to having the
conversation moving forward it sounds
like you have a bit of a different
posture
on this counter offer than you did
uh to their counteroffer to the uh
american rescue plan
that's true we do um the american rescue
plan was a
uh plan and a proposal that was meeting
uh what we felt was a crisis
situation which was getting the pandemic
under control putting millions of
americans back to work
the president felt as he said many times
as i said many times
there was an urgency in moving that
forward and there was less flexibility
because
he felt the size of that package needed
to meet the moment
we are quite open to the mechanisms of
how his ideas can move forward
it can be in a number of different
proposals that can be
worked through negotiating between
members of democrats and republicans
there are a lot of ideas including the
frontiers bill that
senator schumer has put forward where we
feel there's an opportunity to move
forward
in a bipartisan manner and there's some
overlap with what's been proposed in the
american jobs plan
so we do see it as different we do think
the process will be different
uh there's more time to move forward
there's more time to discuss and
negotiate and we'll take
uh advantage of that at that time
available
um it's now been pretty widely reported
that you're not going to be including
a big health coverage expansion in the
family's plan
and that is what's going to include
reducing prescription
drug costs why did the white house
decide not to include that
in this plan well i will say that the
president is still making final
decisions as is his prerogative over the
coming days about what will be included
in the speech
and the american family's plan and the
final components of that when those
final decisions are made
we'll be a part of that as well he will
definitely talk in his speech
about his commitment to expanding and
increasing access to health care as
is evidenced by the fact that we have
opened up the enrollment period for the
affordable care act
ensuring that more than 500 000
americans that didn't have health
insurance
have it now that's why he's in he
included subsidies in the american
rescue plan to make it even less
expensive
but i will also say even as he's making
these final decisions
that the american family's plan and the
speech on wednesday will not represent
the totality of
every uh priority item for him and every
item on his agenda that he wants to move
forward as president and then finally if
you know my uh
india saw the biggest number of new
cases in in a day
ever yesterday are there any plans to
send
any of the us stockpile of astrazeneca
vaccine or any vaccine
to india uh well let me first say that
the united states offers our deepest
sympathy to the people of india who are
clearly suffering during this global
pandemic and we are working closely with
indian officials at both political and
experts level to identify ways to help
address
the crisis we've made vaccine
cooperation a big
priority including with our quad
partners india is one of our quad
partners of course
and discussing vaccine creation and
distribution for the future
we've also provided 4 billion to kovacs
and from the earliest stages of the
pandemic
we've provided india with emergency
relief supplies
medical consumables pandemic training
for indian state and local health
officials
and ventilators which has been part of
our
effort over the course of time including
1.4 billion dollars in health assistance
to india to help them
prepare for pandemics in the future and
deal with the current one
we're facing so there are ongoing
discussions i don't have anything more
to preview
but we are in touch with them at a range
of levels about how we can help get
through this period help them get
through this period of time
thanks tim sure thing good back to the
infrastructure negotiations
we saw the white house respond pretty
positively at least consider
joe manchin's proposal to raise the
corporate tax rate to 25 instead of 28
percent
as was the initial proposal so should we
read this conversation about
raising the corporate tax rate to 30
39.5
as more of a starting offer well the
president's proposal for the american
jobs plan was about
modernizing and making a historic
investment in our infrastructure
the tax component was about how to pay
for it we're very open to a range of
options
and he has some lines in the sand we've
talked about including not
having american the american people pay
for it or not being on the backs of the
american people
uh as it relates to the capital gains
rates and the top margins that you've
seen reported out there
you know the president's bottom line is
that people making under four hundred
thousand dollars a year
uh should not will not have their taxes
go up so if you look at those these
proposed numbers which are consistent
with what he talked about
on the campaign trail when he was
running for president what i can say is
that will only affect
people making more than one million
dollars a year that's point three
percent of taxpayer
payers or three out of every one
thousand taxpayers
that's even as the top one percent saw
their net worth rise by four trillion
dollars in the middle of a historic
pandemic
so he has some bottom lines of where he
will not budge fast
right uh on in on individual numbers and
who and
who will be impacted uh but he's also
open to discussion
we're hearing that ryze is also
considering in the proposal ending the
child tax credit
even though we've seen progressives even
extending it and using it out
yeah well it's not it's not permanent
currently
exactly so are you extending it or
making it permanent
is that the position the definite
position progressives and
plenty of moderates also say that it
should be extended permanently is that
the position
sure what i was trying to clarify i
apologize is that it's not currently
permanent so the
question is whether it will be permanent
red
the president absolutely feels that that
the child tax credit
provides essential funding and help to
people who need help the most
that's why in the american rescue plan
he increased the child tax credit from
two thousand dollars to three thousand
dollars per child
and to thirty six hundred dollars for
children under the age of six
and the expansion was the single largest
policy contributor to cutting child
poverty as is evidenced by the chart
we head up we're looking into the
mechanisms and the cost of expanding the
child
tax credit um and that certainly is
under consideration for the american
families plan
yeah it doesn't sound like you guys want
to budge on that one i think you're
confusing though
it's it's cr and i don't mean it's it's
not currently permanent so we're not
we're talking about how long we'll be
extended and so what i'm saying is that
we are quite open we want we think this
child tax credit is valuable it is a
huge it has a huge impact on lowering
the poverty and reducing the level of
poverty in our country
it helps women get back into the
workforce what we're determining is what
we can do and there's a cost of it it's
about a billion dollars a year for every
year
and so we have to figure out how to pay
for it and there's this is all part of
the discussion
that's the question about johnson
johnson really sure um we've seen
so many of the fema mobile clinics rely
on the j j shot honestly because you
don't have to keep it
so cold and it's one shot um fema
confirmed that only
nine of its mobile clinics were still
operational during this last week with
the paws
so is the just how hard it is to get the
moderna and pfizer shots in those mobile
clinics
part of the slowing rate of vaccinations
that we're seeing
i i'm happy to check and see if that's a
factor what i understand the biggest
factor is though
is that uh we're now at a point where we
have reached
you know just two weeks ago only 43 43
it's still a significant percent of
adults
two weeks ago a vaccinate had received
their first dose now it's 52 percent
just two weeks ago only 66
million people had re see had been fully
vaccinated now it's over 90 million
so we're kind of getting to this point
as i think jeff zions touched on this
morning
where we are uh entering a new phase uh
where it is more challenging
we have we don't we have less of a
supply issue uh we have more of a
uh it's incumbent upon us to reach
people and meet them where they are
so um that's the bigger challenge in
terms of the numbers at this point in
time in terms of the
difficulty i think you're asking about
modern and pfizer and how that impacts
getting into mobile
units yeah the the temperature mobile
clinics weren't
really set up to be doing moderna i'll
have to check with our kova team on how
they see that as an impact
and obviously we are continuing to
adjust the way and the means at which
we're getting into
to communities and you know we make
adjustments um
by based on what we think is the most
effective obviously the increase
massive increase in pharmacies is a
reflection of that reduction in some of
the vaccination sites
we also make evaluations by where it is
most impactful to invest and
some of what we've been doing lately has
been increasing our investment in
community health centers
in primary care physicians uh obviously
in pharmacies but i will check with our
team and see if that's a factor go ahead
thank you jen with the president's first
trip abroad in june that's going to be
the first time a president has actually
traveled internationally since the start
of the pandemic and i'm wondering if
by the time he leaves to go on that trip
in june is he going to lift travel
restrictions to europe
as well i i can't make a prediction of
that that is based on
the uh health and recommendations uh the
health and med the advice and
recommendations of our health and
medical
team um and i don't have anything to
predict on that front
have there been conversations about that
given he is going to be traveling
internationally about whether
it can be a period where everyday
americans also start resuming that kind
of travel
well i would say i think most americans
would see it as
slightly different from the president of
the united states i'm not suggesting
other
you're saying otherwise but as the
president of the united states making a
diplomatic trip
abiding by covet protocols and flying on
air force one
then whether it is safe for mass numbers
to fly internationally
obviously everybody wants that to be
reopened europeans we do american people
who would like to travel
but uh you know those conversations are
really happening between health and
medical
experts and will they make an evaluation
based on what they think is safe for the
american public okay thank you and on
climate you know there have been a lot
of questions about the president's new
announcement about what he wants to see
by 2030 yeah but i think there are still
questions about the specifics of how
they're actually going to get there
so there have been studies that have
suggested that to get to
that kind of a goal more than half of
the new cars and suvs that are being
sold
at dealerships would need to be electric
right now it's only about two percent
is that something that the president
agrees with that they need to be
at half of those being electric by 2030.
you know that's not a goal that
that's not an a a number or a goal that
he set because he feels that
there are a number of ways to get there
and that i saw that reporting as well
that's an example of a way to get there
but there are additional ways um you
know including that impact a lot of
sectors from electricity transportation
buildings industry and lands
our view is there are a lot of pathways
to get to reach this goal
some of it will be done through
legislation through
laws that will be put in place some of
it will be done
to incentivize investment in areas like
electric vehicles
and electric charging stations which is
already happening in the private sector
right a lot of the car companies will
tell you this is where the future of
their uh their industries are going
anyway but we want to incentivize and
make that something
that we can jump start in a lot of those
industries but we've there are a lot of
options for how we get there and so it
isn't just one pathway to get there
okay sorry i've got one more question on
this emergent facility
in baltimore that of course has been
plagued with issues it seems like and
now u.s regulators have
conducted a study and found that they
did not follow proper manufacturing
procedures they had poorly trained staff
that resulted in the contamination of
materials that of course
ruined what could have amounted to
millions of johnson and johnson doses
this is a company that got 630 million
dollars
from the federal government under the
trump administration but is that a
contract that you are going to keep or
has there been discussion about
canceling that contract and not working
with this company given
they have not produced one usable dose
of the cobia 19 vaccine
well i think some of the astrazeneca
doses did come from there but uh
that have gone to other countries but i
will say that
um we we believe the united
u.s st i will say to um take some
pressure off of the or take some
criticism off of the former
administration there are a
limited number of manufacturing
facilities that have
the capacity as you know you've been
covering this for some time that have
the capacity and have the ability
to produce a vaccine like this in this
capacity in size and numbers
there's no question hence they haven't
been approved by the fda for
manufacturing that emergent has not met
those bars and over time has not met
those bars in terms of
future contracts i don't have anything
to predict on that front
um but we'll consider continue to look
for the fda to give
the you know for it to meet the fda's
bar before we are providing vaccines
from there to the american people so
you're still going down that path
for this facility to get approved by the
fda despite the number of issues that
they've had
well again they have to make changes
obviously the fda is working closely
with them
um and if they make those changes and
they meet the fda's bar
that's a different story we'll see what
happens okay go ahead maria
thanks janet uh will the first lady be
attending the president's joint address
next week uh
and what she had guessed as has been
traditional in those those cases
it will be a little bit different um
because obviously there will be a
limited number of people who
are um in uh in the capital uh and a
limited number that will be determined
uh by the speaker's office in terms of
who will attend uh and who will
have to watch virtually well most of our
staff if not all of our staff will be
watching virtually
in terms of whether dr biden will
physically be there in person i'll have
to check on that
mario in terms of the box there will not
be the traditional box
um you know we're determining uh how we
can of course engage the public and
ensure
we highlight some of the incredible
stories of people who have been
helped by the president's policies and
proposals but it will not look like
uh or feel like uh in many ways what
past joint addresses have
for those that will be attending are is
the president's preference that those
people be vaccinated as well this is all
i would send you to the speaker's office
and they are determining attendance and
requirements uh
for those who are attending and then a
couple more questions uh any update on
nira tandon's uh appointment to the
administration at all
i don't have any update the president uh
remains interested in and committed to
finding her a position uh
in the administration and uh taking
advantage of all her talents
last question has the president spoken
to the families of either dante wright
or makaia bryant in recent days i don't
have any calls to read out for you mario
i will check and see um if he's
had conversations with any of those
families too um
go ahead jeff uh jen follow up on india
you said that
your discussions about how to help can i
just ask specifically if the us
is helping with their with their
shortage of oxygen right now is that
something that the the shortage of
oxygen let me let me check on that for
you jeff i mean we
have provided obviously a range of
funding over the course of time it's a
huge significant amount of funding we
are likely one of the world's largest
contributors to
to india in terms of you know
their health needs um and it's gone to a
range of
supplies and training but i will check
if oxygen is specifically a part of how
we can help at this point in time and
their ongoing discussions so it may be
that that's part of the discussion now
okay um also on vaccines the european
union
uh said today that it is close to
finishing a contract with pfizer
to have what would be the largest uh
contract for vaccine
for the coming years um is the u.s in
tops with pfizer as well to get more
vaccine
for post-2021 i don't have anything
about
i'm not going to be able to read out at
any point any contract discussions with
any vaccine supplier i can assure you uh
having worked with jeff science many
times over he is an over preparer and
committed to oversupplying
the united states as evidenced by the
amount we've purchased
to date um and obviously we're cognizant
about the needs in the future
um but i don't have anything i probably
won't have anything to follow up with
you on contract discussions
okay just lastly yesterday i think mario
mentioned
the stock market dipped a little bit in
response to
the uh reports about your tax plans
just wondering what the white house is
feeling as a reaction is to that
are you concerned about wall street's
support or lack of support
for these policies and to what extent
does that play into your discussions
i've been doing this long enough not to
comment on movements in the stock market
but
i did see just data factually that it
went back up this morning
uh go ahead go ahead
um back on healthcare there's a
disagreement among congressional
democrats about how to use the savings
from
lowering the government's cost on
prescription drugs whether to put it
into
expanding medicare or put it into the um
expanded savings expanded subsidies for
the affordable care act
is that something that the white house
is going to take a position on are you
going to let the
congressional democrats work that out in
any health career
well the president absolutely wants to
lower the cost of prescription drugs and
knows the burden on americans and
seniors is far too high he's talked
about that on the campaign trail i
expect we will be in discussions
about what the plans are and what the
options are
but we're not at the point to talk about
that publicly quite yet
go ahead thanks jen on the on the border
the administration has
repeatedly cited the use of title 42
to demonstrate that the border is not
open this is a trump policy that
progressive groups are
increasingly arguing that it denies
migrants who are flying
fleeing violence and persecution a right
to even apply for asylum
i i wanted to know what is the uh the
white house's message to these groups
who largely are supportive of this white
house who are concerned about the
continuation of this trump policy
well franco i would say first that um we
consider it a policy that was put in
place or that we've continued to
implement because we're still in the
middle of a global pandemic
and that keeping the american people
safe and ensuring that we are taking
responsible steps as it relates to the
pandemic is
front and center for the president and
certainly that's what we would convey
to any of these groups at the same time
we absolutely believe
that we should be a country that we are
a country
that wants to treat people humanely uh
as is evidenced by our efforts to
um treat uh children who come into this
country
uh who are under 18 who are coming as
unaccompanied children
in a manner that was not the same as the
former administration
so we understand and we have heard the
frustration about this issue but our
objective
uh as uh the president's objective is to
keep systems in place or keep policies
in place or
implement policies that help us address
the pandemic
you have some goals or some uh some
goals of when you may be able to lift
title 42 i can't make a prediction of
that that that will of course be uh
based on
uh what the evaluation is by our health
and medical experts on
the status of the pandemic and the
safety of the american people can i ask
you just
follow up on the turkey question sure i
mean turkey is a nato member
is is the administration taking into
what consideration is the administration
taking into the concerns
uh that turkey has about uh potential
this weekend's activities i i certainly
understand all the questions i just
don't have anything to
i'm not going to get ahead of the
president or get ahead of any decisions
or
announcements um and obviously any
decision that the president makes on
foreign policy takes into account
uh concerns uh expressed by allies and
partners around the world
can ask one more about immigration sure
you know as we approach 100 days
uh obviously kobe 19 was the biggest
challenge that this administration faced
yeah but immigration was another one
that took a lot of
oxygen uh and political uh time from
this white house
is there any uh does a white house feel
like it could have communicated anything
differently done anything differently
to address this challenge not only
republicans but even some
democrats um have been concerned about
some of the messaging
well i would say there's no question
we've recognized that this is a
challenging issue and we knew that it
would be
when the president changed the policies
of the former administration when he
came into office
and obviously welcoming in or
ensuring that we had the capacity we
were using resources
to treat children humanely and ensure
they're safe
is a change in the last administration's
policy that was going to dissatisfy some
who were supporters of the last
administration but not satisfy enough
uh as you've as as you alluded to in
your question some who think we should
well be welcoming
many more across our borders um so it
certainly is an issue as you know you've
covered this quite closely
where we recognize we were never going
to satisfy everyone
and what the president's objective has
been is to
uh you know focus on the unaccompanied
children
those who had been ripped from their
parents arms those who were
being asked to take a treacherous
journey back ensure we could take steps
there he also wants to push for uh
comprehensive immigration reform
providing a pathway to citizenship
ensuring we're investing and addressing
the root causes in these countries
that's something he announced on day one
of his presidency
so we are well aware and there was some
reporting this morning that
uh this was an issue that uh some
supporters of the former president and
some republicans in congress apparently
are licking their chops about how to
make children a political issue
we don't see it that way and we felt
this was the moral
right step to take and uh we're gonna
keep working with immigration advocates
with groups
out there to get this bill passed to get
dreamers uh the dreamers legislation
passed
that continues to be a big objective for
the president
go ahead thanks jen is the president
aware of the shooting death of
andrew brown a black man from elizabeth
city
north carolina and does he believe that
body camera footage from the police
officers
involved in the incident should be
released he is aware of it um i've not
talked to him about uh
his particular view on that and i
believe he'd likely leave that up to law
enforcement others to work out
do you have another does white house
have a comment on that particular
incident
as well obviously uh they're the loss of
life
is a tragedy and obviously we're
thinking of the family members in the
community whose law who have lost
another who have lost a loved one um
there'll be a
an investigation into this into this
uh shooting or into this death and uh we
will look for the outcome of that
okay on infrastructure you would noted
that the president will travel next week
to georgia
uh immediately after his uh joint
address is what we're calling it this
year is joint address to always the
joint address in the first year of a
presidency
a little history note yeah after his
joint address
do you have any other travel that you
can preview for us
even if you're it's just to say how
frequently you expect the president and
the vice president
to be traveling to sell this
infrastructure package especially now
that all adult americans are eligible
for the vaccine
well again the president will travel on
thursday as well as friday expect i'll
have some additional travel in the weeks
ahead of that
you can also anticipate the vice
president the first lady the second
gentleman will be out traveling in the
weeks after the joint address certainly
they'll be talking about the jobs plan
as well as the american families plan
that the president will lay out in
detail
at his joint address but i don't have a
prediction in terms of how many days a
week it really depends we plan week by
week
and what is needed and uh where we and
we balance of course with needs at the
white house
two questions about republicans you also
had said that the president would be
meeting with
bipartisan groups of lawmakers to talk
about his infrastructure package after
that
do you have any republican senators that
the president plans to meet maybe a
summit that he plans to have
aside from the meetings he had last week
moving forward he's about to release his
second infrastructure package
it's not an infrastructure package it's
a family's plan focus on child care
um and uh helping ease the burden on
families so
american families plan i expect uh he
will of course
welc probably invite in bipartisan
members as a
continuing conversation about the
counter proposal on the american jobs
plan
and certainly anticipate he'll have more
members of congress in
in a bipartisan manner in future weeks
next week you kind of have a sense of
what the week looks like right i mean
he's gonna
be preparing for the joint address he'll
make some remarks he's gonna travel two
days so you can anticipate it it would
be after that
the context of the question is that
there are republican senators such as
marco rubio
or mike lee who have said in the past
that they are supportive of things like
the child tax credit and even extending
it but they don't want to see things
that they
in their view see as well for assistance
or permanent and
permanent entitlement such as you know a
federal paid leave law or child tax
credit extension
so does the white house see some sort of
bridge that they can uh
so can they how does the white house
think that they can bridge that divide
between the republicans who are
supportive of this generally
but but don't want to see permanent
entitlements in their view well
i would say first um in someone you
didn't mention senator romney has also
proposed his own child tax credit plan
and you mentioned a couple of others who
have spoken in support of
uh extensions of the child's tax credit
in different versions we see that as an
opportunity to discuss an opportunity to
seek
bipartisan support and uh on a tax
credit that we think would be
beneficial to families across the
country children
getting women back in the workforce and
so i expect the president will certainly
have
a range of conversations and he'll
continue to have members into the oval
office i think
go ahead i'll go ahead sorry it's a
little i can be more clear
go ahead emily so much um so lawmakers
from across new england are pushing
for funding for high-speed rail line
between new york city and boston
in the infrastructure package i was
wondering if president biden is
supportive of this idea
and how does he envision his
infrastructure plan will spur the
development of high-speed rail in the
u.s
well it will certainly be a part of it
um and when secretary budo judge was
here he talked about this a little bit
and
part of the conversation that members of
congress are having or we're having with
members of congress
is what the composition of grants are
there are some grants that will be
specific to individual projects there
are some that will be competitive
there will likely be some that are
funding that goes to
states that's how transportation funding
has worked in the past and we expect it
to be
a combination so um that will be part of
the discussions that are happening
moving forward i've no question as a
person who grew up in new england that
there will be many advocates um
for that from the new england
delegations um and
uh but we're not quite at that point
that's that's a part of the nitty gritty
decision making and discussions that are
happening now
can i just clarify though um as a huge
rail supporter
can you can you clarify whether it is it
is his goal that this infrastructure
package will
uh either advance or start a new
high-speed rail line in the u.s there's
only one
under construction now certainly
high-speed rail is part of an option
of in investment and as the president as
you know as you alluded to the president
is a big
fan of amtrak and railways himself uh
but
uh we have to work through with congress
what the different mechanisms are for
funding
where we fund the projects are they
through states are they through
different grants and
so that's part of the discussion and the
nitty gritty negotiation happening in
the coming weeks
thank you and just on behalf of two
colleagues who couldn't be here
um does the president plan to visit
ireland when he is making his trip to
the uk
in june well i announced the the
confirmed parts of his trip
at this point in time i don't have any
additional stops
to add but the trip is two months away a
month away six weeks away it's all
running together
um and if we have more trips or
components of the trip to announce uh we
will do that but
there's not a currently a planned
ireland stop on this trip go ahead
thank you jen uh the administration has
given itself until i have a question
about refugee admissions sure
the administration has given itself
until may 15th uh to
decide whether it's going to revive
upwards its cap of 15 000 refugee
admissions
between now and september 30th what
would be a reason for not going all the
way up to the
cap that the administration communicated
already to congress of 62
500 well we have every intention of
providing the president has every
intention of providing an
updated number um that will uh be
significantly higher than the number
from last week because the intention
he was trying to convey last week or we
were all trying to convey was that
we were resuming flights and that we
were overturning
uh the policy of preventing individuals
refugees from applying from parts of
the middle east and parts of africa but
i'm not going to get ahead of the
process we're
assessing what's possible we're
assessing um
uh that through our policy and legal
process and we'll definitely have an
update of an increased number uh in
advance of may 15th
given that that number 62 500 was
already communicated to congress earlier
this year and as a cap
limit it's not a commitment to bring in
that many people why not just go right
up to that cap
and that limit what's going on and
certainly we'll take that into
consideration you're right
and in that this cap is historically
aspirational
uh if you look back at history most
people don't most administrations don't
actually meet the cap
uh but it is sending a message to the
world about uh the fact that we are a
country that welcomes in refugees that
we want to get our
systems and our muscles working and our
refugee uh
processing systems both in the country
and around the world
there were some limitations this year
that were unique to this year in part
because of kovid
in part because of the fact that the
systems were decimated under the last
administration
we just have to take a look at all of
that but i think it's an important point
you touched on that i'd highlight that
oftentimes this is an aspirational goal
and one that we are just trying to reach
to send a message to the world about who
we are as a country
does the bible administration see
increasing the number of refugees
admitted each year as a part a long-term
solution to helping alleviate
the pressure on the border people who
come to the united states illegally
because they don't have other legal
avenues
does the administration see increasing
the refugee
the number of people allowed in the
refugee program as a long-term solution
to
the number to resolving the uh pressure
on the global
i don't think we see it through the same
prism exactly like that it's an
interesting question
uh the president's cap or the
president's objective has always been
consistently from
february through last week welcoming in
125
000 by the end of next fiscal year so
really what we're talking about here is
what the goal what the cap
is for this fiscal year and as i
mentioned we've been
uh dealing with a few challenges but
we're assessing that we will have an
increased number
very soon uh but as you know a lot of
these refugees are not coming
you know they're coming from all around
the world they're coming from africa
they're coming from the middle east
they're coming from many parts of the
world um and so
while it's all related because it's it's
representing who we are as a country and
welcoming
people who are freeing persecution
freeing challenging circumstances
i don't think he sees it exactly through
that prison do you have an update on the
number of refugees that have been
admitted into united states
under the bidet administration over the
last week or so
or over the last few weeks i think we do
have numbers i'm happy to get those to
you after the briefing we've seen
because of flights resuming uh we've
seen um
you know an increase even just over the
last week um go ahead
i just go back to the trip to europe the
uh statement today mentions a bilateral
meeting with boris johnson do you know
any of the priorities that will be
discussed at that meeting and
just relatedly um a couple of years ago
um
president biden before he was president
obviously
said he thinks boris johnson is the
physical and emotional clone
of donald trump but does he still hold
that view
i don't have anything yet to preview for
you about the agenda
a lot of it will be dependent on what
the world looks like at that moment in
time but there are a range of issues we
of course discussed with our
partners in the uk that i expect will be
on the agenda
so as we get closer we'll have more to
say and of course the president is
meeting with him as a fellow
global leader in the global community
and it certainly sends a message about
uh the special relationship we have with
the united kingdom that this is uh his
first trip
and also the the nato summit uh
president trump always liked to claim
that uh he was successful in getting
nato members
to pay more does this administration
think
president trump deserves some credit for
that and about that element of his
approach that this administration will
continue
i know he thought he invented that but
having worked in the obama
administration i can say that the
objective has always been
encouraging members of nato to pay more
pushing
members of nato to pay more and that's
consistently been the u.s policy for
some time
go ahead thank you jen follow up on
david's question
on the trip to the uk would president
biden like to
meet the queen would you like to meet
the queen
we're still who wouldn't want to meet
the queen um
don't you um well we're still finalizing
what the details are of the trip
um so i i certainly understand the
interest i'm interested as well myself
um and we will have more to share with
all of you as the final details are put
together
okay and now on the climate uh summit
president baden just said
that the announcements from brazil were
encouraging
my question was it enough and does it
change the administration perspective
about a possible bilateral climate deal
uh
with brazil or possible assistance to
brazil related to the amazon
well first let me say that reaching
carbon neutrality by 2050 10 years
earlier than previously committed and
with no preconditions as
uh president bolsonaro announced
and his commitment to double funds
available for enforcement are crucial
steps
to eliminate toward eliminating illegal
deforestation by 2030 and so we were
pleased
uh that he recognized the important role
of the and we're also pleased to
recognize the important role of the
private sector in helping us
find solutions uh we agree with his
emphasis
on the necessary involvement of
indigenous people and traditional
communities and protecting
protecting standing for us and
biodiversity and with his recognition of
the important role of the private sector
and helping us
find solutions we look forward to
continuing to work with brazil to
continuing the dialogue and
we feel that his announcement yesterday
was a good step forward so
as a does it change this perspective
about a possible sending assistance
bolsonaro also
asked for assistance uh to protect
amazon
i have nothing to preview in terms of
that but certainly his announcements and
pronouncements
were received positively here i expect
there will be a great deal of follow-up
lots of discussions from our climate
envoy
and others who are leading this effort
from the administration so it would now
be a good time to call the brazilian
president to have a call between the two
presidents
i don't have any calls to preview for
you there's a lot of uh there are a
number of officials including our
special envoy who are leading the
efforts
for follow-up from the summit it
certainly is significant that we had 40
global leaders
some of the world's biggest economies
and emitters here over the last two days
well virtually here discussing this and
there'll be a great deal of follow-up
from here
gen one more so today the discussions at
the cemetery around
clean energy um a lot of discussions
about solar energy
would president biden consider bringing
back the solar panels
here in the white house at the white
house oh that's a good question i will
have to check with our
probably the the gsa i will have to see
who makes that determination but
we are pro solar panel around here so i
will see where
things stand on that front last one
we didn't hear much about the connection
between epidemic and
um the deforestation during this summit
and science shows that about 70 percent
of epidemics
start with deforestation so uh what is
the binding administration doing to
reduce the risk
of future pandemics emerging from areas
experience high deforestation like the
amazon
well certainly addressing deforestation
is not just a
a climate issue it's a big climate issue
it's also a health issue and
uh you know we are encouraged again by
the announcements made by the president
yesterday and we will continue to uh
work with a range of countries around
the world and through international
forum to uh to ensure the world is
preparing for
preventing the next pandemic there are
discussions here in washington about
creating a global fund
for these specific points so is would
the white house support
a global conservation fund uh to
stop deforestation in order to prevent
future pandemics
again there'll be ongoing discussions
with brazilians with many of the leaders
who attended yesterday
uh at the level of our climate envoy and
others who are running points on this
and
i'm certain there are a range of issues
that will be brought up but i don't have
anything to get ahead of
on that go ahead does the president
still plan to issue a statement
uh on armenian victims tomorrow
uh i don't have anything to predict i
expect he will have a statement
uh but uh marking the day but i don't
have anything uh to confirm for you or
predict about the content
and another question um the israelis are
sending a high-level delegation here to
washington next week
to discuss the administration's efforts
to rejoin the nuclear deal and also to
stress their objection to that
how does the white house view this visit
and
and
is it likely to change the this
administration's position and rejoining
democracy
uh no but i will say that uh one
uh there are ongoing discussions or
negotiations i should say
that are happening now they're indirect
of course
on the potential for a diplomatic path
forward on the
on a nuclear deal um well we knew they
would be challenging we're encouraged
that there are still conversations
uh between all parties and that they are
still uh
they're still happening uh as it relates
to israel we have kept them abreast as a
key partner
of these discussions uh or of our
intentions and we will continue to do
that
on any future visits okay oh i have one
oh hello um as we've been doing uh in
our tradition
every friday we uh welcome in uh someone
who can't be here physically with us in
the briefing room so this is
natasha lindstrom of the pittsburgh
tribune review and i understand not to
embarrass you natasha but today's your
birthday
is today your birthday oh we can't hear
you
uh-oh i got it sorry it is my birthday
today so it's a great opportunity to
be here thank you well happy birthday
thanks for spending a few minutes with
us here today
um so how can we help you or what
questions do you have for me
i was going to say to the press corps
but that's not actually how this works
but go ahead
that would be great
many long-standing problems nursing
homes across western pennsylvania
and nationwide including facilities that
have gone under staff
and demonstrate a history of poor
infection control and ineffective
management lung
coped there's also been the trend of
distorting poor performing operators
owned by complex floods of private
equity investors
shell companies increasingly snapping up
hashtag facilities
across our state around the country the
setup can make it hard to figure out
who's in charge
and where the money is going it also can
allow owners
to distribute accountability should
anything go wrong
and it makes it tough to follow the
money even though the majority of the
budgets are
federal taxpayer dollars via medicare
medicaid payments
legislation in various forms to improve
nursing home quality and transparency
has been has bipartisan supports
including bills put out by the likes of
pennsylvania senators bob casey and pat
toomey
a bunch of it has stalled for years now
during the pandemic we have seen an
increase in scrutiny by the likes of hhs
and cms
one of the more egregious cases a
federal grand jury investigation is
underway
linked to some of the operators here in
allegheny for counties in our region
can you elaborate on what concrete
actions are being taken or will be taken
moving forward
on regulatory legislative investigative
or other fronts
to ensure accountability and
transparency in the long-term care
sector
how can we make sure that federal
government states and owner operators
are all doing what they should be doing
to improve the level of care
even beyond code great well thank you
natasha and i think there's no question
that from the president's standpoint
that uh the impact on seniors what we've
seen happen in facilities around the
country
especially in the early days of the
pandemic when there clearly weren't the
preparations in place when there weren't
the systems in place
when loved ones couldn't even engage
with or reach
their their their members who were
staying in in these senior
care facilities it exposed what a
problem we have on our hands
as you noted uh there's legislation
that's in congress um
and uh certainly we we will look forward
to taking a look at that more closely
um and i expect as we are getting to the
stage where we
the pandemic is hopefully under control
that's our objective in the coming
months um
that we will all take a look at and
reflect on what changes should be made
for the future
to be better prepared to take better
care of our seniors to take better care
of our
communities in the future in terms of
regulatory actions i just can't i'm not
in a position to get ahead of that i'm
happy to
see if there's anything underway that we
would be able to speak to uh from here
but i think you have clearly identified
a challenging issue that's not only
uh a problem in pittsburgh or in western
pennsylvania and parts of pennsylvania
but
we're seeing in states across the
country uh as well
there's a lot of landing gets thrown
around you know the states
um blames owner operators on our
operators they don't have enough
resources
the feds play in the state whose
responsibility is to really make sure
meaningful change happens
um even beyond the pendant because a lot
of these problems that were exacerbated
by the pandemic but have existed for
many years
especially with the lack of transparency
element you're right i mean it's really
it's really both it's not just one or
the other i mean there are
responsibilities that the state has
because there's certain funding that
goes to the state to deploy in a lot of
these areas
but there's also responsibilities of the
federal government to look across at
different states and see
these challenges that are happening what
we can do better by our seniors what we
can do better for the standard of care
in these caregiving facilities uh and um
you know i think it's really a
partnership and both uh moving forward
well thank you so much happy birthday i
hope you have a wonderful celebration
this weekend and thanks again for
joining us
um great well thank you everyone as i
promised yesterday i promised snacks
um i did not bring them in here but my
mother-in-law made homemade chocolate
chip cookies
for you guys so um there's one for each
of you in here we will do it in a
covered safe way
but thanks everyone and have a great
weekend
you